il y aura bien une nouvelle élection
pour désigner président et vice
président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines le tribunal
administratif a décidé d'annuler le
précédent scrutin du 9 janvier dernier
expliquant que les conditions d'accès au
public n'avait pas été respectée la
majorité de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
majorité de droite a décidé de ne pas
faire appel elle évoque des polémiques
politiciennes et souhaite un apaisement
alors nous avons décidé de ne pas faire
appel par rapport au sudoku des
magistrats dit même si je la conteste et
même si aujourd'hui les éléments de mes
avocats nous donner toutes les raisons
de pouvoir gagner en conseil d'état
simplement ça va encore faire six mois
de retard et en cours beaucoup d'argent
dépensé pour moi cette nouvelle élection
est un non-événement donc je
représenterai exactement les mêmes
délibération que j'avais présenté au
mois de janvier on c'est à dire que
toutes les communes de gauche seront
représentés dont le bureau par contre il
n'y aura pas de délégation offerte à la
gauche